>> Will Sentance: Ethan sẽ vì nó sẽ tiếp tục đến Ethan.
>> Ethan: Vì vậy, hàm người dùng lưu trữ một đối tượng nhưng
nó có thể chứa bất cứ điều gì khác ngoài các chức năng phải không?
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, hoàn toàn, hoàn toàn.
>> Ethan: Và bạn cũng tham khảo nó theo cách tương tự.
>> Will Sentance: Yeah, yeah, nhân tiện, chúng ta sẽ gặp lại bạn sau
trên cũng có thể có một thuộc tính proto ẩn trên đó.
Chúa ơi, sau này Ethan đi trước.
>> Ethan: Vì vậy, đối số mà object.create chấp nhận là,
đó luôn là Proto?
>> Will Sentance: Đầu tiên, điều đó luôn được nghĩ đến trong Proto.
Vâng, rất tốt, cảm ơn bạn.
Bạn muốn theo dõi về điều đó?
>> Ethan: Không, chỉ làm rõ thôi.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, đó là một câu hỏi làm rõ.
Nói theo cách khác.
>> Ethan: Thay vì tham khảo MDN vào lúc này, tôi chỉ hỏi bạn.
[LAUGH} >> Will Sentance: Đó là sự thật,
object.create tạo một đối tượng rỗng với thuộc tính proto ẩn.
Bây giờ, tôi sẽ nói điều này, thuộc tính đó không bị ẩn như thuộc tính phạm vi Lexical của chúng tôi.
Cái mà bạn không thể nhìn thấy, hoặc mảng đã hoàn thành của riêng chúng tôi.
Không có bảng điều khiển nào hiển thị điều đó vì một số lý do.
Thuộc tính ẩn này nếu bạn sử dụng công cụ Chrome Dev để bảng điều khiển ghi nhật ký user1,
bạn sẽ thấy mũi tên xuống nhỏ trong bảng điều khiển công cụ Chrome Dev.
Nếu bạn nhấp vào đó, bạn sẽ thấy thuộc tính proto này và
một liên kết đến cửa hàng chức năng của người dùng.
Vì vậy, đây là một trong những ẩn nhưng bạn có thể nhìn thấy nó.
Vâng, nhiều hơn nữa, hãy tiếp tục.
>> Ethan: Về mặt kỹ thuật, nó không được dùng nữa nhưng bạn có thể sử dụng .getPrototype của tôi, tôi nghĩ,
đó là một phương pháp mới để thực sự nhận được nó một cách chính thức.
>> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc.
>> Ethan: Nhưng trình duyệt có thể sẽ di chuyển __proto vì nó
kinda được tích hợp sẵn mãi mãi.
>> Will Sentance: Hoàn hảo, chúng tôi duy trì tính nhất quán của lịch sử JavaScript.
Xuất sắc, luôn làm việc với nó.
Được rồi, mọi người, vậy bây giờ,
vâng, bây giờ chúng ta hãy thực sự tiếp tục và
chạy phương thức gia tăng đó.
Có bối cảnh thực hiện của tôi, tôi đã sẵn sàng để đi.
Hãy để 'thực sự rõ ràng, như mọi khi,
ngữ cảnh thực thi này đã biến mất, bật ra khỏi phía mã.
Hãy vào và chạy tăng dần.
Bộ nhớ cục bộ là bình thường.
Hãy đặt nó ở đó.
Tôi muốn hỏi điều gì đó, mã số gia tăng chúng ta có thể thấy tôi
đặt nó vào một dòng ở đó, nhưng, Braden, mã của nó là gì?
Chỉ cần cho tôi những từ chính xác, những gì tôi đôi khi yêu cầu
để liên hệ bằng những từ chính xác, phải không?
Mã của nó là gì?
>> Braydon: Đây. Điểm ++.
>> Will Sentance: This.scorel ++.
Đây là vấn đề, chức năng gia tăng này không cần hoạt động trên người dùng 1,
không cần hoạt động trên người dùng 2, không cần hoạt động trên người dùng 403.
Vâng chính xác.
Tất cả bọn họ.
Vì vậy, phương pháp gia tăng này.
Tôi đoán nếu tôi muốn làm việc trên user1, bên trong nó,
Tôi sẽ cần viết user1.score ++.
Để họ có thể đi tìm chúng tôi, người ta tìm tài sản của trường và thực hiện nó.
Nhưng vấn đề là sau đó chạy nó user2.increment và
bên trong chạy bên trong của tăng đã chạy user1.score ++.
Vì vậy, tôi cần phương pháp này để hàm này hoạt động trên user1 hoặc
user2 hoặc user4 hoặc user405.
Đừng hoảng sợ, tôi có một điều tuyệt vời.
Tôi trong bộ nhớ địa phương của tôi quá nhỏ với tôi.
Tôi có một thứ tuyệt vời được gọi là tham số ngầm.
Điều đó có nghĩa là một, tôi thậm chí không xác định.
Nó tự động ở đó và tự động điền cho tôi.
Và nó được gọi là cái này.
Ngay sau khi tôi bắt đầu chạy phương thức này trong bộ nhớ cục bộ của mình,
bạn biết tôi nhận được gì không?
Không cần phân tích cú pháp chế độ xem chỉ tự động,
Tôi nhận được một trình giữ chỗ tham số ngầm định.
Ý nghĩa tiềm ẩn Tôi không viết nó, nó ở đó cho tôi, cái này và
bạn nghĩ nó sẽ tự động được gán cho nó là gì vậy Todd?
>> Todd: Người dùng1.
>> Will Sentance: Người dùng1, bất cứ điều gì ở phía bên trái của dấu chấm đó,
vấn đề được chạy trên đó, trên đối tượng đó.
Bất kể đối tượng nào ở phía bên trái, sẽ có User1.
Trong thực tế, tất cả các chức năng và toàn cầu tự động tuy nhiên điều này nhưng
bên cạnh một số trường hợp thú vị khác mà chúng ta sẽ thấy hôm nay
rằng điều này luôn luôn có một cuộc nói chuyện về nó.
Trong quá trình tạo của người dùng, chúng tôi đã có điều này, nhưng
nó đề cập đến một cái gì đó không quá hữu ích.
Đây là một khái niệm đối tượng toàn cục vui nhộn trong cửa sổ JavaScript hoặc
đối tượng toàn cầu bạn có thể đã nhìn thấy nó một hoặc hai lần.
Và vì vậy nếu chúng tôi thử và sử dụng cái này, bên trong một người tạo người dùng,
chúng tôi sẽ chỉ ra một số đối tượng toàn cầu vui nhộn.
Một số loại vật thể nhỏ ngẫu nhiên.
Nó sẽ không có nhiều công dụng, nhưng thay vào đó nó là một hàm tăng thêm,
do đó được gọi cho đối tượng người dùng 1 hoặc người dùng 2.
Nhưng do đó cần phải tổng quát, có thể sử dụng lại trên từng đối tượng này.
Ơn trời, chúng tôi có thông số ngầm này.
Người giữ chỗ nhỏ này, đây là một quy tắc quan trọng nhất của chúng tôi, nó luôn gắn liền với
đối tượng ở phía bên trái của các dấu chấm mà chức năng đó đang được chạy.
Vậy .score ++ Todd, đánh giá biến thành cái gì?
>> Todd: User1.score ++.
>> Will Sentance: Rất hay, Todd.
Use1.score ++.
Người dùng 1 không có trong bộ nhớ cục bộ, chúng tôi hướng ra toàn cầu, nó đây.
Cho điểm, tăng nó lên 4.
Đẹp, vâng.
Dân gian, chúng ta sẽ thấy một công dụng lớn khác của điều này.
Keyword, chúng tôi bắt đầu, mọi lúc một người dùng chính khác trong một thời điểm.
Nhưng hiện tại, đây là công dụng chính của chúng tôi, hãy chạy một chức năng được chia sẻ hoặc
sẽ có sẵn cho nhiều đối tượng khác nhau thông qua liên kết proto.
Và đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi viết nó với từ khóa this để truy cập vào đối tượng mà trên đó
, hàm đó đang được thực thi ở phía bên phải của dấu chấm.
Thích người này.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, Jason.
Chúng tôi sẽ đến Mark.
Jason đầu tiên, sau đó đến Mark.
Tiếp tục đi, Jason.
>> Jason: Chúng tôi có đang làm việc rõ ràng với không gian tên khi toán tử này đang hoạt động không,
vì các yêu cầu về phạm vi mà nó phải đi tìm để tìm ra giá trị của chúng ta.
>> Will Sentance: Tất cả chúng ta đều hoàn toàn biết rằng bên trong của đây là
liên quan đến, nó chỉ nằm trong ngữ cảnh thực thi này.
Cái này đến từ đâu vậy?
Chỉ trong giây lát, chúng ta sẽ thấy rằng chúng ta có thể chơi với nó theo một số cách thú vị.
Chúng ta sẽ gặp trong giây lát, Mark?
>> Mark: Đây có phải là bối cảnh thực thi cục bộ không?
Chúng tôi đang nói rõ ràng về điều này.
Nhưng nó đang truy cập điểm số trong bộ nhớ toàn cầu, hoặc
thay đổi nó mà không nói giá trị trả lại, điều mà chúng tôi đã làm theo truyền thống.
>> Will Sentance: Chắc chắn rồi, vì vậy bạn đang nói điều này có thể giống như,
bạn thận trọng về điều này như một loại tác dụng phụ.
Vâng, hoàn toàn, hoàn toàn, và đó là lý do tại sao, nhưng
nó hoàn toàn tiêu chuẩn trong mô hình này.
Và nó vốn dĩ không có vấn đề gì.
Nhưng đó là lý do tại sao chúng ta phải chấp nhận điều đó, nếu chúng ta sử dụng mô hình này,
nếu chúng tôi sắp xếp mã của mình, sẽ có sự đánh đổi.
Lợi ích to lớn, dữ liệu của tôi hoặc chức năng của tôi hoặc
tính khả dụng của chức năng đó được đóng gói ở một nơi.
Vấn đề, xung quanh chức năng, nó có thể gây ra hậu quả ở bất kỳ đâu trong mã của tôi
tuy nhiên, lý tưởng nhất là chỉ trong đối tượng mà tôi đang cố gắng nhắm mục tiêu.
Nhưng việc duy trì loại cơ sở mã này chắc chắn có thể có những lúc thăng trầm.
Câu hỏi rất công bằng từ Mark.